er lobte wir haben bundesinnenminister
seehofer auch gerade schon mal gehört er
will die gamer szene stärker in den
blick nehmen
sehen sie gamer da unter generalverdacht
ich glaube herr seehofer besteht hier in
erster linie durch eine gewisse ahnung
es armut dadurch dass er von der gamer
szene spricht wir haben in deutschland
über 30 millionen menschen die
regelmäßig videospiele spielen da
wünsche ich viel spaß bei der gamer
szene das worauf aber tatsächlich recht
hat ist dass in diesem bereich was
online spiele vor allem angeht 1 eine
communitys tatsächlich dazu neigen ins
rechte lager zu kippen und dort auch zu
kommunizieren
ich glaube also das ist tatsächlich
richtig ist dort genauer hinzuschauen
das muss allerdings mit einer expertise
geschehen die herren seehofers weit
überschreiten sollte aber wie macht man
das dann genau oder genauer hinzuschauen
gut bei über 30 millionen menschen die
spiele spielen ist vollkommen klar dass
da noch ganz andere faktoren mit dabei
sind wir haben innerhalb dieser gaming
szene die sehr diversen übrigens ist der
hefte ungefähr sind wohl frauen aber im
innerhalb dieser gaming szene haben wir
bereiche wo es tatsächlich auch um
verherrlichung von gewalt geht man darf
das auf keinen fall so pauschalisieren
ich glaube schon dass ich da ein
internationales ein globales netzwerk
herausgebildet hat von rechtsextremisten
und das ist der kern
hier sind menschen die zwar auch im
gaming bereich unterwegs sind die aber
in erster linie antisemitisch
rassistisch und auch frauenfeindlich
kommunizieren und die sich auf diese art
und weise finden und sie missbrauchen
regelrecht die instrumente die für gamer
und generell geeignet sind und das ist
glaube ich der richtige ansatz das vom
kopf auf die füße zu stellen
zunächst zuschauen wie arbeiten
rechtsextremisten und dass die auch mit
gaming plattformen arbeiten das ist
2009/10 relativ klar wahrscheinlich den
meisten menschen die auch klar gewesen
außerdem innenminister eben die cdu will
jetzt dieses eckpunktepapier
verabschieden und fordert darin unter
anderem dass man messenger dienste wie
whatsapp stärker oder besser bewacht
überhaupt die die kommunikation darüber
wachen kann brauchen wir so eine
verschärfung der mittel oder reicht das
aus was die ermittlungsbehörden schon
können
mir kommt es nicht so vor als wären
immer neue abbau geschwindigkeiten beim
abbau von grundrechten die richtige
antwort darauf es ist in der tat schwer
messenger dienste zu überwachen
es ist aber einerseits nicht unmöglich
und andererseits glaube ich dass bisher
die behörden schon mit den daten die sie
längst haben komplett überfordert waren
und zwar gerade im bereich rechts
denn das ist der kern dieser ganzen
debatte rechtsextremismus wurde über
jahrzehnte in deutschland regelrecht
verharmlost kleingeredet in eine ecke
gedrängt von das sind nur ein paar
spinner und das ist das eigentliche
problem
und dass diese leute diese
rechtsextremen netzwerke inzwischen auch
moderne medien benutzen
das ist ein anderes problem ich glaube
zuallererst brauchen wir eine haltung
eine art antifaschistischen konsens in
der bundesrepublik deutschland so hat
zumindest max collectors genannt würden
sie also sagen die ermittlungsbehörden
machen beim kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus bisher keinen guten
job
ich glaube nicht dass die behörden
bisher einen guten job machen ich glaube
sogar im gegenteil wenn wir uns
anschauen wie auch unter seehofer und
leuten die seehofer im amt gelassen hat
mit dem nsu skandal mit dem nsu debakel
umgegangen worden ist wie der akten
unter 120 jahre verschluss gehalten
worden sind die bis heute behauptet wird
es handelt sich um drei einzeltäter
dann sehe ich die längst vorhandenen
daten werden strukturell falsch
ausgenutzt ich sehe überhaupt nicht
warum man dann noch neue daten braucht
vielen dank für das interview sascha
lobo über den kampf gegen
rechtsextremismus